le times of market au centre eaton le 4
août à la place ville-marie le central
dans le quartier des spectacles à
montréal
les aires de restauration haut de gamme
poussent comme des champignons et les
gastronomes en raffolent enfin c'était
toujours chinois pitt the fish and chips
et maintenons c'est plus court mais en
vrai presque tu es dans un lancer leur
merveilleux décor soigné
mobily conçu par des artisans locaux
pour en mettre plein la vue le 4k est
mandaté la firme cite les attentes ont
complètement changé la clientèle qui
vient manger aujourd'hui avoir un
environnement qui qui va lui plaire
c'est pas juste un grand espace avec des
pioches tout autour on a on a créé une
segmentation ce modèle de gastronomie
sur le pouce est déjà populaire en
europe et aux états unis
ici on mise sur les saveurs locales les
premiers ratés qu'on avait avec le sens
est de permettre aux restaurateurs
indépendants installés aux entrées
diminue les barrières et d'un marché qui
est très compétitif sur les arbres
espace de mutualiser certains services
pour justement faciliter l'opération et
une jambe auberge espagnole
tout le monde est responsable depuis
c'est son produit mais capte quelqu'un
qui fonctionne mais qui contamine les
autres voisins aussi à fonctionner dans
ce marché ultra compétitif touchées par
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
y at il vraiment de la place pour ces
relais gastronomique nouveau genre
probablement selon la chroniqueuse
gastronomique leslie chestney est ce qu
on avait besoin de ça non mais
maintenant que je les vois je trouve ça
la qualité est là les prix vont avec
c'est pas les mêmes prix qu'on pêche et
valentine c'est bruyant on entend ses
bruyants lieu du monde si on revient aux
heures de pointe c'est très simple un je
trouve ya beaucoup d'amour dans ces
aires de restauration
on voit des gens travaillent fort qu'il
le résultat est spectaculaire le même
genre de concept verra bientôt le jour
où promenades saint-bruno ou encore au
centre fairview pointe claire
de plus en plus d'arriver à démocratiser
une cuisine comme celle ci c'est
essentiel puis je pense pas du tout que
ce soit un effet de mode c'est c'est
plutôt vers la conserva l'ouverture de
ces nouveaux pôles gastronomique fait
assurément le bonheur des amateurs de
bonne chère mais il faudra voir s'ils
réussissent à coexister sans
cannibaliser et à faire mentir
l'expression trop de chefs garde d'assos
messina directeur chartier radio canada
montréal